yeah Allison yeah so in the model that
you set out with globalization being
driven by power if you don't have a
value based system driving it what's to
prevent to the you know and bring faith
into the the picture what's prevent it
the instrument mental ization that we
have touched around so bye-bye forces of
power whether it's the state or people
or what's to prevent faith from being
used to perpetuate systems of inequality
for example the church has a history of
standing on the side of the Empire you
know so in today's context how do you
negotiate that well I think you
negotiated in this way I mean first of
all that there is a as Isaiah a simple
reason for doing this corson having this
examination and then there's a sort of
them a greater ambition the simple
reason is that face there I haven't
shared by billions of people so and the
first thing we should do is just
understand what that process means and
and one of the things that I think it's
important that we do in the course of
our studies is actually get a grip on
what faith really does mean two
different people in different cultures
and that's if you like a that's somebody
you can have aptly you could be like my
dad and a militant atheists and still
think that's an important discussion to
have because it it matters to it matters
to the world but then I think if you've
got a boulder ambition which is to say
how how can faith and actually be viewed
as something that is positive and
progressive then I think you know we do
have to examine but this is for a little
time down the way what is the what is
the basis of of faith you know what is
it that truly motivates people in terms
of faith
you know is it is it something that is
actually exclusionary to other people to
come back the yeses first point or is it
is it not really that's why I say you
know some when i look at faith just from
a practical kind of practicing
politician point of view you see these
different strands with in faith faith is
my badge of identity faith has this is
the tradition but faith also as
spiritual awakening you know faith is
about how I can be a better person not
how can I enforce this form of faith or
this form of culture on everybody else